[Música]
si alguna vez has deseado tener el poder
de ser invisible
muchos de nosotros en algún momento de
nuestra vida hemos deseado hacer
y es que cuando nos imaginamos que
podemos aparecer o desaparecer a
voluntad
creo que se nos vienen a la cabeza cosas
bien divertidas
cómo escaparnos para una pieza a la que
no nos dieron permiso de ir
o hacerle una broma a un amigo
de pronto escuchar esa conversación de
tanta curiosidad nos genera
pero qué pasa cuando ser invisible
no es una condición que se pueda
controlar
qué sucede cuando ser invisible es algo
que se convierte en algo permanente
para muchas personas como yo
ser invisible se convierte en un estilo
de vida
pero quiero hacer un paréntesis aquí
para explicarles
qué es lo que hace que un objeto se
vuelva invisible
leyendo sobre el tema encontré que hay
varias formas
una de ellas es cuando la masa del
objeto
no es capaz de reflejar la luz
esto qué quiere decir los rayos de luz
atraviesan el objeto y por lo tanto se
hace invisible a los ojos del observador
pero hay otras formas por ejemplo cuando
escondemos el objeto
cuando lo camuflamos con su entorno o
cuando lo ubicamos en un lugar
completamente oscuro
yo aprendí a hacerme invisible como
mecanismo de defensa
pero con el tiempo esto se convirtió en
mi cotidianidad
me escondía detrás de malos hábitos
alimenticios en algún momento de mi vida
me llevaron a pesar más de 90 aquí
me camuflaba para pasar desapercibida
cuando hacía a un lado mi cuidado
personal y ponía de último mi autoestima
frente a lo que yo creía
era mi deber en la vida era ser buena
mamá
buena profesional buena esposa buena
hija y buena hermana
y me sumió en la oscuridad absoluta
cuando me negaba a socializar con
personas que no estuvieran dentro de mi
círculo más cercano
y así debajo de todos los kilos con la
autoestima destruida y en la soledad más
absurda me convertí en la mujer
invisible
me superpoder era hacer invisible
pero hace poco leí en un foro sobre
superpoderes encontré
de ser invisible no es tan chévere
porque cuando eres invisible te quedas
ciego
y el argumento de la persona que debatía
en este foro era que
nuestra visión funciona cuando la luz y
las imágenes se reflejan en los tejidos
de nuestros ojos
si somos invisibles
no se refleja y por lo tanto no podemos
ver
en mi caso se trataba de ceguera mental
y era una ceguera que no me permitía
reconocer mi propio potencial
y así como harry potter
me arrope con mi capa de invisibilidad
era calientica y cómoda mientras veía
pasar la vida
pero en el fondo era porque tenía una
voz dentro de mi ser
y me decía que yo no era suficientemente
bueno
que yo no merecía nada mejor
hay que inventar algo nuevo
me conduciría irremediablemente al
fracaso
y entonces me sumí en ese círculo
vicioso
y todos estoy segura que todos en algún
momento de nuestra vida hemos
experimentado y ese es el momento en el
que sabes que no eres feliz
que no te sientas bien pero no haces
absolutamente nada para resolverlo
pero había días en los que yo me
levantaba así como felipe y decía hoy es
el día voy a bajar de peso voy a hacer
deporte podía estudiar voy a hacer esto
voy hacer aquí
pero así o felipe ni siquiera terminada
la oración no pasaba nada porque yo no
hacía nada
yo no lo sabía
pero necesitaba algo que me sacudiera
que me llevara de la intención a la
acción
y ese día llegó y por lo general cuando
llegas llega con lo que más te duele
hija mariana tuvo un accidente en un
entrenamiento de patinaje
y se fracturó su bracito
ella pasó de ser una niña deportista
atlética
a tenerle miedo a patinar
y por lo tanto como hábitos sedentarios
y ganó un poco de peso
en una de las consultas de control con
suerte pediste
me atreví a preguntarle
porque sería que la niña me estaba
manifestando que tenía mucho dolor en
sus huecos públicos
para los que no saben los huecos
propicios es como se le conoce a esta
parte de atrás de la rodilla
aprendieron a
y la respuesta que él me dio con una
frase corta clara y contundente
una frase que me sacudió el mundo
y sus palabras fueron y abro comillas
papá gordo
mamá gorda
niña gorda
y fue en ese momento que yo hice
consciente
de que yo no era tan invisible como creí
y se conciencia de que había alguien que
me estaba mirando fijamente
y no solamente es
repetía todo lo que yo así
y entonces llega esa pregunta que te
golpea como un rayo
y me dije qué clase de modelo a seguir
soy
qué es lo que le estoy enseñando a mí
ese día
tomé la decisión de emprender mi primera
pequeña acción
descargue una aplicación móvil en mi
celular
y con una disciplina casi religiosa
logré bajar 14 kilos en 7 meses esos
pases ya un ratito
y empecé a cambiar pero el cambio no
solamente es por fuera así como se ve
allí es también por de un cambio
emocional
había decidido empezar a estudiar
y por una confianza renovada me gradué
con honores de mi especialización
pero no solo se queda allí decidí seguir
estudiando y hace un mes exactamente hoy
terminé las materias de mi maestría
empecé a reflejar la luz
y me di cuenta de eso cuando en el banco
donde trabajo como analista de crédito
me entregaron una carta en la que me
importaban un cargo diferente
y esta carta llegó después de haber
tenido una conversación con la gerente
de gestión humana del banco en la que le
decíamos que como equipo de trabajo nos
sentíamos invisibles
la frase fue tan fuerte y caló tan
profundo en ella que cuando me entregó
la carta me dijo carolina
esto es para que tú te des cuenta de que
no eres tan invisible como crees
derivando
hay personas que están viendo tu trabajo
y este es el momento de mostrar
cinco meses después regresé a mi puesto
pero era una persona diferente
tenía una nueva visión de negocio
había descubierto talentos que no sabía
que tenía
y había renovado mis ambiciones y me
saque
acaso eso no es un gran cambio
decidí encender la luz del cuarto oscuro
y salir de mi aislamiento social
y aunque a veces puede parecer
antipática al principio es solamente
porque me falta parar
hoy tengo un grupo de amigos
maravillosos estoy segura están viendo
esta transmisión por streaming
y allí arriba tengo mi barra
y he conocido personas super valiosas
después de intercambiar números de
teléfono habiendo tenido una
conversación por ti
hoy entiendo lo importante que es
generar redes y conexiones de valor con
las personas
y una pequeña acción almorzar con el
amigo de un amigo lo conocen
me tiene aquí para delante de ustedes
contándoles esta historia
son pequeñas acciones sostenidas
disciplina mantenidas en el tiempo
es que me ha llevado a ver grandes
resultados
y cuando tú te acostumbres a hacer cosas
nuevas pues cosas interesantes pasa
y yo tomé la decisión de que iba a
empezar a hacer las cosas que me da más
miedo hacer
y lo hice porque cuando haces esas cosas
que te dan más miedo lo demás parece un
pase
le tengo mucho miedo a volar a subirme a
un avión y en blog me pongo
pero en el último año he salido dos
veces del país y ha tomado más vuelos en
los últimos diez años de mi vida
y es tan interesante en el último vuelo
hasta dice un amigo
me da mucho miedo hablar de finanzas en
público
porque aunque sé que soy muy buena en lo
que hago
sé que hay otras personas saben mucho
más que yo
aún así este año decidí grabar un vídeo
y postear lo en línea invitando a la
gente a que leyeran mis artículos sobre
finanzas para pymes
y ese vídeo y mis artículos han tenido
un feedback súper positivo de pares
mentores y expertos en el tema
cuando conocí a carlos le dije que yo no
me sentía digna diferente
y aquí estoy
quiero compartir con ustedes más que mi
historia lo que he aprendido en este
viaje
lo voy a resumir en tres puntos
fundamentales
1 hacerte visible no es cuestión de un
cambio extremo
no tienes que dar el salto cuántico para
visibilizar
son pequeñas acciones sostenidas
disciplinadas y mantenidas en el tiempo
las que te llevan a ver los cambios que
quieres en tu vida
siempre hay alguien que está viendo así
tú te sientas invisible
a mí me estaba viendo a mí
a ti quién te ve
los chicos
tu pareja
los amigos los colegas
hasta esta pregunta qué clase de modelo
a seguir tiene fe
tercero
todos necesitamos ser notado
y esta puede ser una frase poco
problemática no me gusta figurar
septimio
no conozco a nadie a nadie que no tengan
nada bueno que ofrecerle a los demás
todos tenemos algo que aprender y todos
tenemos algo que enseñar
y esto me lleva a una frase que me
gustaría que se llevaran grabadas con
juego en el año
y es que hacerte visible es atender un
llamado de servicio a los demás
nos han hecho creer por mucho tiempo que
tenemos que brillar con luz propia como
bombillos
pero no es así
la luz es la misma para todos
lo que nos hace diferentes y únicos es
la forma en cómo reflejamos esa luz
hazte visible
permítele a las personas que te rodean
conocer tus matices tus talentos tus
dones con el conocimiento que tienes al
servicio de los demás
yo te invito a que te inspires a la
persona que tienes al lado a través de
tu es muchas gracias
[Aplausos]